متخفيا وخائفا يتوجه مهدي الى هذه الغابه
يقطع منها ما يتيسر من الاشجار استعدادا
للشتاء رغم ادراكه ان ذلك يخالف القانون
الجبليه والبرد قارس في الشتاء لذلك انا
مضطر لقطع الاشجار وجمع الحطب لضمان
التدفئه لاسره واطفالي
كانت مساحه الغابات في اقليم كردستان
العراق بحسب سجلات وزاره الزراعه الا ان
نصفها اختفى لاسباب متعلقه بالجفاف
والحرائق والقطع الجائر رغم فرض القانوني
عقوبه لا تقل عن السجن سته اشهر وغرامه
ماليه تقدر بنحو ثلاثه الاف 5300 دولار
على اكثر من 100 شخص بتهامي حرق وقت
الغابات الشعب لدينا نقاط في جميع الغابات
وكذلك دوريه لكن هو رغم ذلك سجلنا في حدود
محافظه السليمانيه منذ بدايه العام قطعه
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف شجره
من الغابات في اقليم كردستان خلال العقد
الاخير ما يثير قلقا شطاء البيئه التي
تعمل جاهده لوقف الحاق الضرر بالطبيعه
والتمدد العمراني
من جهه على الارشاد باهميه حمايه البيئه
على الزراعه ومن جهه اخرى نحاول الضغط على
الحكومه لتوفير الوقود والكهربائي
للمواطنين لتجاره قطع الاشجار
تزداد المخاوف من خساره الغطاء النباتي
والغابات عمدا لذلك تطالب هيئه حمايه
البيئه بتشكيل محاكم خاصه بالبيئه
ومرتكبي جرائمها انحسار واضح للمساحات
الخضراء والغابات الطبيعيه ينظر بزوالها
ما لم تكثف السلطات المحليه تدابير
الحمايه القانونيه للثروه الغابيه وسط
ازمه الجفاف التي تلاحقها بالتزامن مع
التغيرات المناخيه في العالم
تستاهل حكيم الجزيره السليمانيه